[Musica]
non c'è
dire qualcosa che tocchi
ha iniziato DS noi
[Musica]
com'è la mia
tra un po' di tempo
[Musica]
proprio come la corsa del fiume è andata
bene
ma so quali cambiamenti devono arrivare
[Musica]
è stato un  gira
ma temo
dimmi
[musica]
è stato
ma cambierò quella macchina
[musica]
sono andato da mio fratello
e gli ho chiesto se
potevi gestire la
malattia
[musica]
ma  e tutti i miei cambiamenti devono arrivare
oh yeah
[Musica]
[Applausi]
non c'è tempo per noi non c'è posto
per noi cos'è questa cosa che costruisce i
nostri sogni eppure ci scivola via
[Musica]
ooh
non c'è possibilità
[Musica]
il lato di noi
Oh
dolce
detto di salvarla
[Musica]
in contatto ma
tocca il mio
quando
è oggi
[Musica]
è tutto oggi
tu
[Musica]